and President Trump is threatening to
send more troops to the southern border
after a sharp increase in the number of
people stopped from entering this
country Customs and Border Protection
figures show more than 92,000 migrants
were apprehended crossing the border
back in March and that is the highest
total in more than a decade cities along
the border are struggling to handle the
surge Mireya Villarreal is at one point
of entry that's in Hidalgo Texas with
more on this story
Matea good morning to you well good
morning the border chaos has created
this sort of bottleneck here at the
border right now there are trucks that
are trying to transport goods into the
United States some of them have been
waiting for days to get across the
bridge a government official tells me
there is a shortage of manpower right
now because they are diverting resources
to respond to the influx of migrants
government officials say the number of
migrants crossing the southern border
continues to grow our Rio Grande Valley
affiliate KGB team was there when two
men from Mexico were caught hiding in
thick brush they say they paid a
smuggler two thousand dollars to get
them into the States if I am a senior
this father from Ecuador says he gave
his life savings to a smuggler to bring
him and his two children to Texas we
have seen in excess of millions of
dollars each week made by the cartels
and the smuggling organizations and a
lot of that is dependent on how much
traffic we see is it like this every
morning every morning crowds of migrants
fill the bus station in Brownsville
Texas waiting for transport to shelters
didn't our volunteer said here Cordova
provides water and snacks to help the
migrants get through the day and some of
them don't have shoelaces their stuff
they don't have stuff they just have
what the clothes on their back
immigration advocates say these people
are fleeing in such large numbers
because of the extreme poverty and
violence they face in Mexico and Central
America do these people understand that
they are breaking the law when they come
in illegally is that their intention to
scam the system it is not these
individuals are very humble very scared
individuals who are just trying to make
sure that their children are protect
Vice President Mike Pence will be
visiting the border in Arizona he'll be
taking a tour of one of the stations
down there we've also confirmed some of
the military personnel that is expected
to reach the border later we'll be
helping with logistics as well as
administrative duties and also some
medical support Nora right Maria
thank you so much